this is what i love about ramdas
one of my teachers is he you know ramdas
you've heard of him this guy
you know it rings a bell he was he was
so he was hanging out with tim leary
at harvard and they were the professors
they got kicked out of harvard because
they were
like uh taking lsd and giving lsd to the
students
and because they were interested from at
first because they were both like really
brilliant
uh psychologists they did and this was a
new substance and they thought they had
sort of
like discovered what was going to be the
next phase of uh
human evolution or a new tropic that was
going to like completely accelerate the
civilization uh they get kicked out
of harvard at the time ronda's name was
richard albert
and so they're like exactly where any
any of us
have been where it's where we're running
into this seemingly like built into the
matrix
inhibition thing that they uh that
currently what do they call it tolerance
and so
so they're literally drinking lsd like
sandoz laboratory 1960s lsd
out of vials like liquid lsd drinking it
because i don't even
know droppers because i didn't drive a
dropper
out of like [ __ ] yes
i'm naughty look it's crazy there's
about the harvard psychedelic club yeah
because you know they're
on acid you do get a tolerance really
fast yeah but they were running into the
same problem
and so the reason so albert goes to
india
with a like [ __ ] ton of acid
that owsley you know you know have you
ever heard of owsley that bear he's like
the dancing bears on the
grateful dead that that's owesly's
nickname he was the lsd chemist of the
dead like uh steely dan kid charlemagne
it's a whole song written about him
it's it's you know he's his famous uh i
know someone who
went with him delivering acid in san
francisco and said
these [ __ ] hippies they'd come out of
their house and they
they call it pranayama i think pranayam
they fully bow
prostrating to him you know like which
is why there's a line in the steely
dance song which is like
did you feel like jesus you know because
he was like blowing over his mind anyway
he makes a special batch for albert
who takes it to india to give to people
who've been meditating
for you know their whole lives and ask
them what the [ __ ] is this
and you know some people loved it some
people
said this is a waste of time but he
meets his guru this is one of the famous
crazy [ __ ] stories
um and his guru says to him like you
have something you want to give me
give it to me what do you have and so he
gives him this [ __ ]
powerful acid to this old man in a
blanket
who eats it and no reaction
nothing happens he gives him like a fl
something for us
that for me that's fetal position like
500 micrograms
like you know that's weeping fetal
position
what have i done i'm never coming down
no response no reaction
albert gets back to the united states is
telling his psychologist friends this
story they're like he got swindled he
pawned
he put in palmed it you know he
obviously didn't [ __ ] eat
no one's eating 500 micrograms of lsd
and having zero reaction
physiologically impossible so the next
time
he's with this guy neem crowley baba was
his name he says to him
the last time you were here did you give
me something
and he said yeah because this guy was
telepathic and there's no other way to
put it and he goes
what did you give me what did you give
me and he said
lsd and he said did i eat it do you
think i really ate it because he knows
he's thinking he didn't really eat it
and he's like give me more give me more
so he gives him
a massive doom dose
like i don't know how many capsules
these are capsules of this stuff
what does the capsule look like i mean
like you know when you get the
uh it's in you know like a [ __ ] pill
you know like a dyed pill is the
substrate that shits in
so he's like he's holding it in his hand
taking one
chewing it taking the other chewing it
taking the other chewing it then he
opens his mouth so he sees like his
tongue
is just covered in like glue and and
then
he like and i now i know people who saw
this from the other perspective because
ramdas told this story a bunch it's a
cool story
but basically he like goes under his
blanket and he starts
shaking like he's having a seizure
moaning
is like oh [ __ ] i just basically just
killed an old indian like i just
i just killed him i killed guru i broke
an old indian man he
was like trying to like flex on me
and or and so then uh after doing this
for a little while
i know people who saw randos who was
like about to cry
face pale probably thinking about
lawsuits part thing about like
how the indian authorities might arrest
me for this [ __ ] like
uh and then he like comes out of his
blanket
and he's like smiling come goes about
his business completely fine you're just
[ __ ] with me you're just [ __ ] with
him like is this what you wanted
me to do is this like what you were
hoping for for did you want to see
something like that
but anyway he says to him at the end of
this day he says to him we used to have
something like this
in the indus valley uh he said
this will bring you into the presence of
christ
but the problem is you can't stay there
with this
and it was like just the most brilliant
articulation of the problem with these
substances which is like
it's affirming what we all already know
holy [ __ ]
it's showing me what's inside the ark of
the covenant like i'm seeing
past the veil and it's real whether or
not sober people or people have never
tripped want to believe that what can we
do but it's real
it's something you're seeing something
more than just like mashing your brain
but also you can't [ __ ] stay there
because it's like
we're in school here can i just tell you
how [ __ ] up my new tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats